alrighty folks so as you will recall we
did a youtube video a while back that
had me reacting to woke videos my
producers decided to torture me with
that but apparently y'all love that so
they get to torture me again so here we
hi go it's your friendly female altar
art and in today's video we will be
switching me and alex will be switching
out who is in front in this video please
give us a like because i know we're
going to get called fake for this
all right here goes
hey everyone it's alex from the a system
the reason me and art can switch so
quickly is because we've been in the
system the longest we've both been in
the system since early childhood do you
think
god stays in heaven because
he too lives in fear of what he's
created for example the switch between
me and asher is a lot longer than that
thank you
um so the beginning i thought that this
person was actually going to perform
some sort of feat of engineering because
they're talking about how they're going
to switch and the switch is going to be
fast i'm like wow we're going to like
build a computer or something
nope we're just going to demonstrate
some symptoms of pretty severe mental
illness and treat it as though that is
like a sign of not only wellness but
higher being art who is a she her and
alex who's a he him are the same human
and switching your voice a little bit
does not make you a different human
being if you actually have multiple
personality disorders to the point where
you actually believe that you are
multiple personalities you really really
need to see a psychiatrist that is a
serious mental disorder
man how do you feel about flat earth
i mean it's flat
you're right you're running with flatter
theory yeah my uncle one time so i'm
from maine i'm a lobster fisherman right
so my my uncle one time
he got in his boat
and he went way past the three
mile line
all the way out towards canada and i
swear to god we never saw that
again he went all the way
past towards canada and i believe
personally that he sailed off the edge
of the earth well there's always the
marianas trench and you know that it
splits the earth in clean in half right
and so if you if you fall off the edge
of the earth you just go straight in yep
yep all right i feel like you can sign
up
um are those people serious
[Laughter]
are you serious like that has to be a
joke right like if they're joking that's
really funny if they're not joking it's
even funnier but sad because presumably
folks like that vote
story time this has been my first year
in preschool with a class of my own
teaching alongside another queer
neurodivergent educator and we have been
rocking our two's class we've been
talking about gender and skin color and
consent and empathy and our bodies and
autonomy it's been fabulous but our
teaching team is shifting and a new
person is being onboarded someone with
many years of experience so today at the
lunch table when the topic of gender and
genitals came up one of our students
plainly looked up and said well i'm a
girl today but i know that teacher co
isn't no they're envy and the look on
the incoming teacher's face was
priceless she was shocked in a good way
and she just looked around at the two of
us and said this class is incredible and
i am so impressed
take your kids away from these people
mom can you pick me up i'm scared these
people should be nowhere near your
children they're indoctrinating
two-year-olds into the idea that they
can change their gender every other day
which is a lie it is an absolute lie it
is not true it is garbage it confuses
children it makes them more depressed it
makes them mentally ill it is a really
really large like why would you why
would you ever put your kids in the
hands of somebody like this why does
this seem like a rational person to you
teaching your two-year-old about their
genitals are you people insane and i
honestly i don't blame this i don't
blame this woman i don't blame her i
blame the parents who the hell are the
parents who decided i'm giving my kids
over to this person this person is an
adult she can do exactly what she wants
to do if she wants to call herself nb or
wimby or humbi or gumby i don't care but
if you are talking about handing small
children over to the predations of this
ideology you are a bad parent you are a
terrible parent you know what you're
right babies don't choose their gender
when they're born
babies
are babies first of all second of all
sex and gender
are
two completely different things
babies are assigned to sex at birth
based on their genitalia
gender
is more of your concept of yourself
it's the way
you innately identify and feel uh
once my child is old enough they'll tell
me how
they feel and
what their preferred pronouns are
i'm crying along with that baby in the
same world cps is on the way you know
this insanity like placing on a child
the notion that the child is going to
choose their own gender
we know what gender your child is boys
have a penis girls have a vagina the
peculiarly
cartesian duality between the gender
soul and the human body that these
people purport to believe in is just
it's it's crazy it's crazy and it's and
it's sad and when it's applied to kids
this is a dereliction of basic parental
duty your job as an adult is to guide
your child through life not to sit
around waiting for your child to tell
you what they think their gender is kids
are not assigned sex at birth any doctor
who says the kids are assigned sex at
birth should not be a doctor you should
be put in a mental institution look dex
the walls are padded i'm a savage
classy bougie ratchet
sassy moody hey mommy dogs can transmit
covered i don't know if the dog is
vaccinated so we have to be super
careful dogder fauci says so that's
disgusting this one's for all the people
who get offended by being called
colonizers so if that's not you you can
keep scrolling the rest of you
i don't ever want to see or hear you
ever again say that you shouldn't face
the consequences for what your ancestors
did
you should because in this exact moment
you're benefiting off of a system that
was built by your ancestors because of
what they did
at the same moment natives like myself
and even younger generations are still
feeling the repercussions of what your
ancestors did
so do not i repeat do not come onto my
page or any other natives page and say
that you shouldn't face the consequences
of what your ancestors did because that
is complete bs honestly pagan tribalism
is when you start saying things like
your ancestors make you responsible for
anything they did in the past and so we
must punish you this is sort of what
biblical values came around to correct
you read hammurabi's code and
hammurabi's code says that the kids can
be punished for the sins of the parents
and then the bible says really that's
not supposed to happen obviously history
has consequences right there's no
question for everyone history has
consequences some of the consequences of
that history are terrible some of the
consequences of that history are good
like that particular native american
woman uh obviously she is using some
sort of sophisticated phone equipment in
order to film this and place it on tick
tock a chinese service there are lots of
consequences to civilizational
development some of them are good and
some of them are bad but to suggest that
people today must pay the price for the
sins of people in 1828 when by the way
one of the great lies that's also been
told about
sort of colonization and and tribal
warfare is that it began with the west
it absolutely did not native american
tribes fought each other to
a bloody pulp for centuries before the
arrival of westerners that's not an
excuse for for western treatment it is a
reality of history but this this basic
notion that i am righteous because my
ancestors were victimized whereas you
are unrighteous because your ancestors
were the victimizers in a particular
situation is a recipe for never-ending
tribal warfare we'll get to more
tick-tock torture in just one second
first let us talk about your home
security very often we have packages
that come to our door and i'm not home
and so i need to be able to talk to the
person at the door well this is where
ring comes in somebody's dropping off a
package or somebody's stopping by to see
one of my kids i can actually talk to
the person they can talk back to me it
is extremely useful and ring comes in
handy all the time with my ring alarm
security system i am much more at ease
when i'm on the road or away from home
because i can check in anytime from
anywhere my ring alarm equals peace of
mind you can protect your home too with
ring alarm ring alarms a powerful
affordable home security system you can
easily install yourself it works
seamlessly with other ring products in
one simple app and keep an eye on every
corner of your house indoor and outdoor
cams see what's happening right from
your phone when i'm at home i've got a
bunch of kids running around sometimes
you just look around and one is gone
where did they go well good news i've
got the app i can tell go to ring.com
for a special offer on a ring alarm
security kit today you can build a
system that is right for your home have
it up and running in just minutes that
is ring.com
again
ring.com for the special deal i've spent
the
summer trying to stay in my little
bubble you know decompress from this
dystopian nightmare we've been living in
for
so long and i'm hearing we have to wear
masks again like what the
like i'm so sick of the same
people everything up for all of
us like first you guys elect trump and
it's like you know thank you very much
for that
and uh then you guys were like oh sweet
let's light tk torches and be openly
racist again
and then you guys were like global
pandemic fake news let's make this way
harder than it has to be and then you
guys were like you know maybe you guys
might have been right about climate
change but it's really too late to do
anything about it so it
and then you guys are like life-saving
vaccine the government's trying to kill
us and you guys are too stupid to take
it and now i gotta wear a mask
again because if you again
jesus christ
what's wrong with you guys
i'm not the one on tick-tock lady like
just ranting into my into my camera
phone tick-tock just seems like a place
for for people with serious mental
problems i like how she lumped everybody
in together there also who is you guys
so everybody who voted for trump
is a tiki torch carrying white
supremacist who also rejects vaccines
also if she's really worried about
wearing a mask like don't really it
seems like you're the one who's trying
to voice something on somebody else why
isn't it default of your politicians who
are cramming down mass mandates if
you're really pissed about wearing a
mask don't and if you're vaccinated
you're safe so what are you whining
about
and corn pop was a bad dude
and he ran a bunch of bad boys one of
the things you had to use if you used
pomade in your hair you had to wear a
bathing cap you
off the board i'll come up and drag you
off
well he came off
and i he said i'll be waiting for you
he's waiting for three guys and straight
razors
not a joke
[Laughter]
that's some that's some solid stuff
right there that's that's good stuff hi
my name is julia i love abortion and
attention it's true if you hold your
hand up like this long enough um people
will stop getting pregnant
actually i'm pretty sure abortion does
make a baby go away
gosh can she stop taking other designers
designs it's actually really not cool
abort it a board a board
a board look at all of the cops here to
make sure that no one steals anything
from sephora
is this the nikki version
what the the pride that abortion
rights advocates take in actual abortion
is kind of astonishing right we went
real fast from safe legal and rare too
please kill my baby kill my baby my
favorite part here is where she's like i
think it does make a baby go away well
at least we're acknowledging the obvious
now at least we're just acknowledging
that you like killing babies so points
for honesty there like really more
points to honesty for this lady and for
most abortion advocates who are like oh
it's just a cluster of souls who means
at least this lady's like yeah it's a
baby and i don't care and i'll kill it
okay so at least we can see your evil on
full display so points for that clarity
is uh clarity is a good thing alrighty
so the honest takeaway from tick-tock
videos is that it is a bunch of people
who have serious problems and have been
poisoned poisoned by the intersectional
wokeness of today ideological leftism is
just an absolute cancer i mean look how
it is screwed with people's heads this
is cancer look at the insanity that
they're preaching and cheering and feel
like they ought to be cheered for the
scariest thing about this is of course
millions of young kids are going to
watch this stuff so it's young kids
watching videos of young people
indoctrinating young children in many of
these cases yeah there's something
seriously wrong with our culture and
that's what these woke videos show
thanks for watching if you want to see
me be tortured a little bit more by my
producers let us know in the comments